This is hands down the most powerful
indicator combo I've ever found. Look at
this chart and this indicator right
here. Every time it shows up, the market
makes a sharp reversal. Not once, not
twice, but over and over again. I've
been trading reversals for the past 5
years, and these indicators make
spotting high probabilities trades
simple and repeatable. Using just this
strategy, I've made over $5,000 in the
last 20 days trading only 90 minutes a
day, 4 days a week. And once you learn
how to use these two indicators along
with the entry checklist I'll show you,
you'll be able to confidently find
trades, whether you're scalping the open
of the market for just 60 minutes or
swing trading overnight. Now, what's
going to make this a profitable strategy
for you is focusing on the four key
pillars of what make you a profitable
trader. The first one is simple
strategies are the easiest. You don't
need to be trading 10 different
indicators trying to capture every move
in the market. Instead, focus on one
simple setup that you can consistently
repeat every day. Now, we'll go over
tools that will help you instantly spot
where to focus on for these high
probability trades and what areas to
completely avoid. These are the same
tools I use every day myself to be able
to trade only 60 to 90 minutes a day.
And secondly, you do not need a 90% win
rate. Just looking at my results right
here, I only have just over a 50% win
rate over the last 20 days. But what you
can see is I make way more money for my
winners compared to my losers. That is
one of the biggest factors to become
profitable trading is focusing on
riskreward, cutting your losers and
letting your winners become big. Don't
get married to one specific trade.
Understand there's always another
opportunity the next day. And doing that
allows you to focus on the big picture
of making consistent money over the long
term versus a single day. And the third
thing is focusing on high probability
setups only. I've only taken a handful
of trades over the last 3 weeks, but
because they are such high probability
setups, I'm able to make good money from
when they work out in my favor. If you
try and take too many trades, it's way
easier to make mistakes and lose money.
I lost money for so long trading. And
what really turned the corner for me was
not trying to be profitable with a ton
of different strategies. Instead,
focusing on becoming profitable with
just one simple setup, only taking one
pattern and one trading style because it
allowed me to master one thing. And the
last one is tracking everything you do.
Most people lose because they are
reacting to the market versus following
one simple strategy. And being able to
track everything you do helps you master
and improve that over time. So now let
me give you an overview of the two types
of ways you can trade this strategy.
Either day trading for 60 to 90 minutes
in the morning or swing trading it over
larger time frames. That's the awesome
part about this strategy is you can make
it fit any schedule you want. And so the
first thing about this strategy that
makes it so simple but high probability
is focusing on the key swings in the
market and those extremes that it
creates to allowing you to know where
the market's likely to reverse later
down the road. And so for day trading a
lot of the time I like to draw these
zones off of a 15minute chart. I'll post
a video up here that goes more in depth
on how to draw those levels manually if
you want to, but I also have an
indicator that automatically draws them
for you on the support or resistance
side. Now, the next biggest factor in
this is using another indicator that
helps you identify when a move is
overextended. What I realized over
looking at charts year after year is
when the market just gets really
overextended,
it's really likely to have a pullback of
some kind. And so I realized that well
instead of trying to predict when the
market's going to have a massive move
like this, why don't I just wait for
this massive move to happen and then I
look to reverse that move. And so what
this indicator does is it tells you
based on these either green or red boxes
is when the market makes an overextended
move in one direction. And so the idea
is if you combine these two indicators
by seeing that the market be
overextended into a key area where the
market's likely to reverse based on
supply and demand zones. Well, it's
makes it a high probability to reverse
lower. And so this combo together helps
knock out 90% of the noise in the
market. Allows you to just focus on the
areas that are important and high
probability to trade, which is extremely
helpful for trading a short amount of
time, but still being able to capture
important moves in the market. And this
is really half of the puzzle. The second
part is knowing when to actually click
buy. And then the whole idea is going
into a smaller time frame chart. You see
it come up into this level. This is on a
one minute chart. You see a couple few
key patterns like here's a double top.
You enter in on a trade and you capture
this massive move down where you are
risking a small amount to make a massive
amount. And that's the power of using
these on a larger time frame chart like
a 15-minute chart and then zooming in to
a smaller time frame chart. And a big
key is knowing when to actually click
that buy button. That is honestly
probably one of the hardest things in
trading because it's so easy to get
wrong. Now, this looks very similar for
if you're just trying to do it more of a
swing trading style. Now, I highly
recommend doing both if you can because
it allows you to just get more trades
basically. Now, the first step is
basically again the same thing. All
we're looking for is well this is a
60-minute chart now is looking for those
key reversal zones either drawn yourself
or with the indicator I'll provide you
and as well using this indicator to spot
okay boom there's a big move up I need
to pay attention now that I've seen this
big move up come into this area and
start slow down and then you can capture
a massive move down and this is after
the market has actually closed into the
overnight session And that's the cool
part about this is it allows you to
trade any time of the day. You know, if
you miss this big move up during the
opening market hours, you can still come
in here on a slower time frame chart.
This is now a 15-minute chart for ending
in on a trade, risk a smaller amount,
capture three or four times your risk,
which is that big key factor becoming
profitable over the long term. Now, a
big thing though is knowing the
difference between when to take a trade
and when to enter in on these and when
to skip it. That is one of the hardest
things about trading that you have to
really master and these two tools will
really help with that. There's a few
other patterns that I think are very
important for you to pay attention to.
Also, I highly recommend getting this
trading platform I'm using. It's called
Ninja Trader. It's super powerful. Has
tons of indicators, tons of custom
indicators. I'll leave a link for in the
description. Now, that was all in
hindsight, but let me walk you through a
real trade where I made over $2,800
while I was asleep. This is the
potential of using this strategy all the
time. And of course, the two biggest
things that we want to see is we want to
be using that indicator to show us that
the market is overextended. All these
green boxes are saying that this is
really overextended to the upside. And
then secondly is it was trading right
here. This is looking at a daily chart
is it had just come up to this area
where the market was likely to reverse.
And so based on hitting those two big
factors, it put me in focus mode of
okay, I need to focus on this and jump
in onto a trade. And so I jumped in at
this price right here and captured a big
swing down overnight. And this is the
most important thing when doing these is
having specific stop- losses and
targets. You can see I put a target for
it to essentially just give this big
move back up right here. And I have a
second one down here if it really starts
to move overnight. And so it moves down.
I take I get out half of the trade while
I'm still asleep at, you know, 4:00 a.m.
And then I wake up and I see where it's
trading. It's starting looking like it's
starting to slow down. And so I
essentially close out here for the rest
of the trade closing out totaling about
$2,800. And going back to my journal, it
was this trade right here where I made
over $2,800 on that oil short. Now,
something super important is you can't
just blindly be seeing these lines that
come across from the indicator and
shorting or reversing because you think
it's going to reverse. If you look at
this chart right here, this was
happening pretty much at the same time
as this move is this is a massive move
up and it's producing a ton of
overextension signals. And the problem
though is if you see it never reversed
this. You could have been trying to bet
against this move the whole time and
lost a ton of money as it had this
massive trend up. And so when something
is super strong and is having such a
strong move, you have to wait for it to
slow down. You can't just see this
signal show up and bet against it. You
want to wait for that clear indication
from it's either coming into a big
resistance zone from that other
indicator or looking at this chart, you
can see it's starting to go sideways and
slow down. And that's when maybe you
want to start thinking about looking for
those reversals. Now, let me walk you
through my kind of final entry checklist
to jump into these trades. Really
knowing when to click buy is probably
the hardest thing in trading. And so I
want to show you through this more day
trading example. Now, super short time
frame. This is on one minute chart. This
trade now this is during the first 30
minutes of the market open. The market
opens 7:30 my time in the morning and I
want to help answer the last few key
questions about executing this strategy
effectively. And so the first thing of
course is using those two indicators is
to see that we're coming up into a key
resistance zone. Again, you can draw
these yourself based on that other video
or I do have an indicator that does it
pretty well automatically. And the
second thing of course is this move was
overextended based on the other
overextension indicator. So you have
those two keys showing up showing you
that this has a high probability to
reverse. That is the biggest confidence
booster when it comes to trade. And this
is what honestly helps me focus on the
process as much as possible is always
making sure that you have those two keys
in place before you even sit down and
consider taking a trade. It helps you
just avoid all the noise when it comes
to trading. And so that's the honestly
the first thing in the checklist is
having a key reversal zone and having an
overextension indicator signal come up.
The next thing is having a key reversal
pattern. What I like to do is look for
either a double top or a head and
shoulders or even in this case it did
essentially a fail breakout here where
it broke above the previous extreme high
got a lot of people in excited thinking
it was going to go higher and then
reversed. And so this candlestick right
here gave me a ton of confidence. And
then the final confirmation was that it
had this little pullback here and then
pushed lower with this big candlestick
confirming a lot of momentum to the
downside. And that is where I
essentially entered in on my trade and
then used my riskreward calculator tool
here to put my stop loss up here and
target a certain amount of risk. You
want to try and keep your risk the same
every time. And then as this moves in my
favor, you know, I slowly move my stop
losses down. And usually the initial
target I have for these trades is if it
gives back up that overextended move.
But you always want to try and let it
run a little bit more just in case it's
going to keep going farther. So this
trade right here had a pretty big spike
down and I closed out right here for
pretty much $2,000 in under 15 minutes
in the morning. Now, if you want to get
these two indicators that make it super
simple to know where to focus on and
spot these key areas of reversal, you
can get them in the link in the
description below this video. And if you
want an even bigger tutorial on how to
execute this scalping strategy every day
consistently, more examples, even deeper
explanation on this, check out this
video right here.